mal schauen wie es dann alles mit dem
neuen projekt was sie mann und ich uns
super weitere planen so wie das dann so
aussehen wird auch mit euch unter
anderem weil eventuell wird auch eine
ding stadt gemacht eine stadt für user
aber da müssen wir noch gucken schreibt
man der kommentare wie sowas begrüßen
würde wenn wir so etwas machen
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge von dem ganz ganz
tollen megaprojekt wo ich ihn vor zwei
folgen vor zwei stunden gefolgt bin vor
zwei folgen gestoppt gestoppt gestoppt
bin gestorben bin bei mir ist es gerade
heftig am regnen und ich hoffe euch hat
das wars rennen horse rennen course
racing mein gott mein englisch und
deutsch vermischt sich wieder so gekonnt
er das ist unglaublich
ich hoffe euch hat das gefallen und wir
bauen jetzt eben ein bisschen weiterhin
im haus
ich werde abend noch mit denen er
aufnehmen da werden wir dann so eine
kleine soziale aktion machen ich dachte
erst das ist jetzt alleine mache und
dann meinen wir könnten wir theoretisch
ob zusammen machen und ja also werdet
ihr dann noch sehen die folgen kommt
dann wahrscheinlich morgen dem material
in der messe fabrik ab da ist er wieder
voll was ich nämlich auch noch machen
wollte war dass ich bei simon einfach
mal reinschauen
warum der so fieldings hatte ich den ton
ein bisschen zu laut gestellt warum der
simon nämlich so eine heftige jupiter
produktion hat und da kann ich auch
eigentlich gleich meine ganzen sachen
der aufladen und zwar dank an alle leute
die wir sachen die kommentare
geschrieben haben von wegen
das portal ist übrigens bergmann hatte
denn seine loading plate hat er diese
überhaupt noch hatte der überhaupt mal
hier eine verstehe ich nicht er hatte
jedoch mal eine oder vielleicht jetzt
egal
das rohr ist auch schon voll wenn es die
meldet sich gerade
nee ich will geht hier ab jetzt nicht
runterladen ich wollte ein kleiner teil
dabei sein weil er meint ich könnt dabei
sein aber ich hab mich näher
also ich nehme einfach mal ein bisschen
von sie meinte dass es immer okay wenn
seinen furor voll ist und schaut euch
sein rohr an und schaut euch bitte jetzt
die kiste an dies directly wieder voll
das ist so heftig aber das ist natürlich
nicht gut
wir helfen die man mal ganz kurz moment
so so geht da rein
dann helfe ich ihnen hier auch nochmal
ein bisschen so schön nach einlegen da
und boa junge das macht doch keinen spaß
mehr wenn man so viel jupiter hat
deswegen will ich auch nie so eine
heftige produktion haben das ist ihr
seht ihr alles rausgeschmissen
ich habe damit nichts zu tun leute ich
habe damit nichts zu tun das ist so
heftig das ist mir glaube ich sogar
schon ehrlich gesagt zu viel
guck mal wie schnell der produziert aber
warum von unten bekommt ihr skript boxen
da rein und es war es auch der bekommt
richtig viel energie wahrscheinlich ne
das ist hier ja high voltage solaria
dann ist natürlich klar wenn der so
heftig viel energie dadurch bekommt er
dann ist natürlich logo warte so jetzt
investieren auch mal so ein paar sachen
mit beziehungsweise lager die ihm hier
unseren paar kisten dass das sieht doch
schon besser aus so eine kiste die so
ein bisschen lehrer ist so man hilft
natürlich wo man kann freunde nehmen
hilft wo man kann so alles mitgenommen
so und da steht jetzt nicht geholfen hat
denke ich mir nochmal das mitnehmen darf
so wir machen jetzt nämlich erstmal ganz
viele diamanten das ist schon mal eine
vorbereitung auf die sache die wir
machen wollten übrigens muss ich meinen
pegel hier noch ein wenig besser
einstellen damit ihr mich noch ein wenig
lauter hörte mich das mikrofon nicht
immer direkt vor meiner fresse haben
muss sondern halt nur halb
so was ich auch noch machen muss war
diese ganzen sport ich muss noch so viel
machen ich denke mal mega projekt
aufnehmen ich bin da fast täglich mit
einem sachen denkst du neue ich musste
erst mal jemand so voll viele sachen
machen erstmal jetzt noch mein haus
übrigens muss ich auch bald man endlich
optimal reinpacken fällt mir ein dass
das sagt ja auch immer mehr wo ich jetzt
auch hier so langsam mit technik anfange
okay natürlich ich hoffe dir einfach mal
so gar kein portale hinsollen habe ich
eine schaufel ich habe einen diamond auf
jeden fall sei mental so heftig schnell
einmal klicken
tschüss sagt sack naja allerdings bevor
ich jetzt mit denen er heute am kauf
nehmen dachte ich dass ich jetzt schon
mal ein kabel an dass ich jetzt schon
mal ein thema mit euch besprechen kann
was zurzeit wieder aktuell ist und zwar
wo ich das jetzt kein extra video machen
sondern da jetzt megaprojekt und kann
man das eigentlich jeder hat eben
abhandeln julians blog battle was man
bekommt wieso kommen die immer rein
ich glaube ich mache jetzt einfach in
das wort damit ich den nano selber nicht
immer ihm die aufladen muss oder komme
ich lad den jetzt einfach mal ja im ofen
lade ich den aufgaben des mad wieso
kriegt er wirklich so wenig ändert sich
jetzt mal kennen julians blog battle
rückrunde ich finde beide runden scheiße
ich weiß nicht warum bei spongebobs
lag's daran den feierte allgemein nicht
so übrigens erst mal kritik zu meinem
anderen natürlich darf man kritikern mit
üben ich möchte ich aber auch kritik am
junior battle gibt und ich mache es bei
dem fest kämpft übrigens das was ihr da
seht moment da und das ist und da das
ist meine softbox hier
das hier ist meine softbox nur dafür
noch eine lampe also einem ersten video
über die hinrunde tune gegen spongebobs
blog battle ging's finale habe ich ja
gesagt dass es für mich nicht so viel
skills hat die tune ich habe nicht
gesagt dass er keine skills hat allem
ein wild natürlich hat spongebob skills
du [ __ ] die ganzen zwölfjährigen
spaß ist die alle vbt gucken und gar
keine ahnung von rap haben sondern
einfach nur das fallen was das studium
halt weiter fest dass sie die besten
also dann will ich euch jetzt nicht
angreifen
sondern es gibt einfach so leute das
sind an julians blogs oder julien
tuning-kit kanal und wie die genannt
werden
wir haben mittlerweile auch schon
eigenen ausdruck und so was alles
jedenfalls voll gut macht selber erst
mal besser als ich meine man dafür
kritik üben deswegen stehen wir an so
einer position wo man eigentlich seine
freie meinung sagen darf
wenn wir das jetzt irgendwie durch ein
paar leute da verboten wird dann gebe
ich dann fick doch na ja jedenfalls was
ich glaub ich hab mir mal nach drogen
scheißegal ich habe noch einen spot mit
doppel a ha ich muss ja noch so viele
lampen machen für meinen teller mensch
du bist fertig oder fast jedenfalls die
rückrunde finde ich ist nicht geil ich
finde die ehrlich gesagt wieso hab ich
ja auch noch scharf auf minimum drücken
zwischen 19 und ich habe sogar noch
diese ganzen bälle hier
scheiße das habe ich gar nicht mehr ist
ich habe ich kann er das natürlich egal
ich nehm jetzt einfach ein bisschen
kilometer marke passiert und zwar die
rückrunde
ich weiß nie wo ich stehen geblieben bin
also bei der hinrunde habe ja gesagt
dass es für mich ein wenig deutlicher
gewonnen hat ein ganz klein bisschen
deutlicher gewonnen hat wenn ein monat
dann aber nur ganz ganz wenig ganz ganz
viel weniger handlich kann ich rede mir
wichtig dass man damit nicht so viel
vorsprung auf jeden fall lag das jetzige
hat alles
jetzt gehts mal was damit diesen server
los cnn firma also da hätte sponge für
mich gewonnen weil er einfach besseres
video bessere locations und so was alles
hat vom flugzeug so was alles und jun
hat einfach die viel besseren punch
lassen bettelt und jetzt hat für mich
spontan gewonnen aber da es bei julian
halt auch auf video zu ankommt finde ich
dass da ging's gewonnen hätte spongebobs
jedenfalls jetzt nächste runde
dingsbums hier ja ich stelle es
rückrunde muss ich sagen hat tune sowas
von klar gewonnen ich meine der bieter
diesmal boss of tune und die lions waren
einfach auch wieder boshaft der punch
ein technisch kann man die nicht
schlagen ich finden kann man nicht
schlagen ich würde gern mal sowie die
sonnensonde neuauflage von hab ich da
gerade ab sodass man daheim enthält ich
dachte da niemand hat so hier oben war
der mv so lacht nlv solar helm wie
tatsächlich dachten dlv blickt euch und
zwar bin ich der klaren meinung dass der
schritt die rückrunde gewonnen und somit
das komplette turnier weil das ist für
mich für mich also wie gesagt für mich
kommt es auf punchlines an und jetzt
kommen wieder allen alemannia wieder mit
argumenten wie ja aber der ist doch viel
geiler und so nach dem motto ich finde
ich finde einfach dass sponge gewonnen
hat weil sportler aber ich finde das
tunen gewonnen hat weil die uhren
einfach die viel besseren punchlines
geliefert hat nehmen wir wieder so viele
sachen august gottchen alter hier muss
ich die ganzen land nämlich aus diesen
lampen wollte ich übrigens meinen boden
hier oben machen
hier oben so ein paar läppischen
reinsetzen da oben rein
naja muss ich gucken wie ich das alles
mache damit hier nicht überall fackeln
drinstehen haben muss darin stehen haben
muss also für mich hat ganz klar team
gewonnen weil einfach scheint technisch
besser besser wenn s video battle
wettbewerb wäre dann hätte ganz klar
gewonnen weil er halt die viel viel
besseren
video aufmachung skills besitzt
beziehungsweise hat ja ich weiß nicht
was mit selfmade zusammen gedreht oder
mit wenders l stoppt das vergessen habe
ich kein plan ich glaube dass mit
irgendeinem studie auf jeden fall
zusammen gedreht
deswegen sieht das auch alles so mega
reißaus und jugendräume bruder hat er
und mehr halt nicht und oder ekz designs
ist glaube ich auch
und die können jetzt nicht fasten gar
nichts nahezu habe ich denke ich auch so
viel jupiter drin
ob ich eigentlich mittlerweile kein juli
meter drin man darf ja fast ja auch alle
schon füllt sich langsam
und das ist natürlich nicht gut jetzt
bei mir geht der progress auch ca ich
würde sagen denn zehnter so langsam wie
bei simon kann ich nicht machen könnte
ich könnte das thema eigentlich moment
moment moment ab sofort
immer so dran schließen einfach an den
msv vielleicht wird er dann als wäre
jetzt die ganzen led diesmal gar nicht
einfach geschlossen
die schilder einfach nur so rum auch
nice läuft bei ihr auf jeden fall ist
die den sieg denn alle hierunter fallen
ja sind sie aber die laufen auch alle
denn die laufen dann brauche ich auf
jeden fall noch ein glas silber cable
ich habe keine mehr kann ich das nicht
auch hier mitmachen oder platz denn
moment momenten menschen
nee das klappt eigentlich sehr isoliert
so hat er jetzt schon viel mehr ja der
hat auf jeden fall sammelt er schon
schneller energie tisch kommt bei dem
von change or brauche ich eigentlich
nicht obwohl ich hab doch axel und so
was alles mit und mensch unglaublich
aber da eventuell nämlich auch mal mit
ich organisiere mich hier gerade so als
würde ich jetzt einige höhlen
besichtigung machen mache ich aber nicht
aber ich habe einfach keine fackeln mehr
dass er so ein bisschen traurig und ich
habe so viel kohle und ich war am anfang
war ich so meint er wir brauchen richtig
viel kohle für diamant und jetzt in
diamant einfach mal fast nix das ist so
witzig finde ich hab ich richtig gelacht
wer zeitig da ein bisschen was gemacht
hier bisschen kohle bisschen mode denn
ohne moos nix los
jetzt habe ich wieder zusätzliche
jupiter was wollt ihr noch mal machen
ach ja ich wollte richtig richtig viel
die haben zu machen
ich brauche auf jeden fall fehlen
deswegen nehme ich jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen und zwar will wollen wir
natürlich auch was mit den ganzen
diamanten machen den und ich das erfahrt
ihr dann in der nächsten folge wo die
folge ist nicht vorbei aber ihr fahrzeug
erst der nächsten folge
so ich geh jetzt mal in so hin denkt
euch bestimmt nicht so viele blogger
werdet ihr sehen
außerdem ist das dann ich glaube ich
kann mir erstmal aus den blöcken 1 2 3 4
5 6 sie ich glaube ich bin jetzt erst
mal ich habe jetzt eine sonde jupiter
produktion hier
von daher ist mir das natürlich jacke
wie hose wieviel diamant nicht erst
verbraucht
ich glaube ich stell mir sondern kreuz
hier drauf gar nicht blender mäßig oder
so ach mensch
es steht aber in diese komisch in der
mitte jedoch passt aber ich krieg das
denn zum leuchten bringt solche leuchten
lampen
ich finds auch kaffee dass mein boden
jetzt hier drinnen überall museum ist
ich muss den einfach eigentlich mal so
ein bisschen hirn ist er bescheid dass
auch sie das siegel das ist geht so mega
schnell mittendrin also normale erde
geht auch noch mal so viel schneller
dass es so heftig ich glaube jetzt jetzt
nicht mache ich nie aber ich mache so
bleibt bis der bescheid nämlich mache
den ganzen boden glaube ich dass irgend
einem anderen material weil dieses
wieder ne das ist doch ein bisschen arg
für die toilette aus und ja also nochmal
um auf das grün ins blog bettelt ins
finale zu kommen meine meinung ist
einfach fortune hat die hinrunde leicht
verloren würde ich sagen allerdings die
rückrunde stark gewonnen mit einem
starken abstand deswegen locker easy
fortune gewinner würde ich locker ii
sorgen lokal sehr würdig echt einfach
mal zu sagen diese braucht auf einmal so
lange auf so der dwd
übrigens bin ich da vielleicht ein
bisschen besser darüber reden kann gehe
ich fliege ich jetzt mal ganz gut zu den
anderen und versucht mir hier links zu
schnappen
so ein bisserl erfahrung durch in
lokalen etc welche nicht durch sagt zack
zack zack so
das schwert hatten in worten schwer
mitnehmen können ich finde das team
gewonnen hat weil einfach die viel
besseren punch 1 geliefert hatte ich
meine mannschaft das gemacht was er
sonst auch gemacht hat also ein super
video ein superhoch finde ich auch ich
habe fast nichts bekomme ich am 5 - aber
danke spark dass ich das hier immer so
wir nutzen darf ich kann ja mal eben hat
der nicht hier nicht dass wir noch
einmal drüber hier das liegt nämlich
alles auf was man in der hand hält so
diamond drill voll dass man rüstung
jetzt auch aufgeladen habe ich jetzt mal
nämlich eben kurz und zwar finde ich
ganz einfach das fortune das ganze
battle für sich entscheiden konnte weil
natürlich hatte der mietzeit uns was
alle sich darauf vorzubereiten
allerdings konnte sponge einfach auch
viel mehr runden zurückgreifen die four
turnier gegeben hat deswegen war das für
beide eigentlich relativ ich sag nicht
einfach panzer heraus zu finden aber sie
haben auch eine menge fans gefallen
allerdings hat vor tieren so was von
deutlich mehr punch es in der quantität
und auch in der qualität rausgefunden
beziehungsweise angewendet angewandt und
gewendet ich glaub angewandt heißt es
dass es bleibt einfach nur spongebob
wurde einfach nur in seinen arschloch
das ist jetzt einfach so muss man jetzt
mal ganz einfach so sagen hier locker
wie ich bin fast voll alter täter
schnell deswegen ich bin jetzt auch kein
richtiger fortune fan oder so ich bin
von spotfire denen also ich feiere die
lieder in die mega geil also so von kann
man echt super so hören und vorziehen
könnte ich selbst zum beispiel gar nicht
wenn ich ihnen die pumpen die oder so
und
spongebob passt perfekt ich finde
einfach dass man es von sport battle rap
ist irgendwie weise nicht spongebobs
könnte so links machen so ganz normal so
rap tracks gegen sie zum beispiel ich
hab mir geht's wie ein komplettes album
wo sie einfach die rap-szene geschickt
haben nicht einzelne rapper natürlich
auch immer bezug auf einzelne rapper
aber nicht so dass man merkt jedenfalls
wenig dass bosch so etwas auch machen
könnte und das würde auch megageil
ankommen dem würde ich sagen und ich
will auf jeden fall feiern wenn er
einfach nicht so detailliert eine person
dessen würde sondern halt so sie steht
ihr was ich meine als wenn man ich es
gibt manche personen die können einfach
bei battle rap keinen bezug herstellen
wer sind denn da so leute bei mir fällt
echt gar keiner ein
punch ist zum beispiel so eine obwohl
die panther wieder nicht mannschaft auch
ein paar runden vor allem vw 2011 was
glaube ich oder 2012 wo er auch ein paar
geile fans gebracht hat also keine
ahnung ich kenne mir fällt jetzt auch
kein rückgrat kein rapper einer welche
in spongebobs ist eine person die sich
nicht so richtig auf die andere person
beziehen kann finde ich jetzt und wenn
er sich bezieht dann sind lügen
naja egal ist eine andere story es für
mich jetzt voll kinder der klare sieger
in diesem bett ich finde auch zurecht
ich meinen des porsche hat sich zwar gut
hochgearbeitet
die gute gute sehr sehr gute
marketingstrategie damit einer maske und
sogar so crowe mäßig des ich sido ja
schnauze allerdings ist muss muss sich
einfach sagen dass ich damit tun einfach
mehr sympathisiere
was den rest angeht nicht so allgemein
so als personen
so objektiv so jetzt einmal ganz kurz
minecraft ich würde das hier alles super
gern fertigten werde ich aber
wahrscheinlich nicht schaffen weil du
mich daran hindern eu bis zu machen man
jetzt wieder erde hin komme ich mir ich
las dass da jetzt erstmal so offen her
wenig verwaschen und das letzte stück
direkt sowie ich letztens haye
also ich will eigentlich das alles hier
aus einem gewissen stein haben außerdem
am besten sonnenlicht stein oder sowas
das wäre auf jeden fall magnus und dann
hole ich mal ein paar erfahrungen wieder
wird das halt wieder ein bisschen
längere folge 30 - das sei auch gut ich
sehe ich schon bald ist ja sechs stunden
dachte zum hochladen oder so ach scheiße
jetzt fallen die ambosse darunter fick
dich ich muss einmal meine ganzen kisten
und so aus dem boden raus 15 kisten
entleeren
wenn ich hab da teilweise echt so viel
kaffee drin das ist unglaublich
so hier noch abwarten wir alle egal da
greifen wir natürlich direkt auf die
schaufel hilfe und manche das ist jetzt
einfach so arbeite das ist arbeit die
muss man machen
dabei könnte ich jetzt auch super das
reden und weil das gericht den reden
dass ihr euch wünscht das wollte schon
lange mal fange ich meine letzten folge
so nochmals schalter soll ich aber schon
ein wenig erschrocken
wegen euch us krieg schon ich habe mich
letzte folge euch schon mal gefragt was
ihr euch so wünscht an anmod
vorstellungen welchem ort sich so
eventuell mal vorstellen könnte die
jetzt irgendwie geil findet oder so
jetzt fange ich euch mal allgemein was
ihr so sehen wollt auf einem kanal
welches video hier so also jetzt die
geraten immer noch dabei sind die leute
die jetzt wahrscheinlich jedes video von
mir gucken weshalb ich euch sehr gern
habe allerdings zu videos wo ich sagen
würde
da will ich hier draufklicken so was
irgendwie soll in der richtung was euch
hat so richtig interessiert mal scheiße
weil man sieht ganz klar megaprojekt
bekommt immer durchgängig also das kann
ja jeder beobachtet da kommt immer so
durchgängig seine man ließ mich aufregt
dass ihr überall was vorne
ich glaub ich stell mir die ganzen
sports ist einfach nach unten halt dein
maul mich verarschen
und zwar so wie die also megaprojekt
thema relativ gut an das kann man auch
beobachten allerdings was ihr euch so
noch zu wünschen wäre würde so sei es
jetzt irgendwie mal dann pvp wartet
moment so verstehe ich den jetzt hin
auch hier habe ich ja auch schon
sei es einmal irgendwie ein bestimmter
pvp modus oder ob ihr dann auch so mal
lieber wieder change accepted wollt oder
halb so ein paar sachen die ihr euch so
interessieren so die einzelnen personen
das heißt jetzt nicht so dass wenn einer
da schreibt hier ihnen wie man den mord
vorstellung dass ihr das unbedingt licon
müsse sondern dass sie einfach auch
kommentiert mit dem was ich zb besser
finden wenn die ausstellung schreibt man
kann dort auch mord vorstellung
schreiben
und deswegen kann ich ja nachher ich
kann der kommentare durchsuchen wie oft
welches wort geschrieben wurde und wenn
ihr dann einfach mord vorstellungen
schreibt alle oder irgendwie sowas dann
ist es natürlich besser als wenn dann
einer vorstellung schreibt das 150
daumen hoch oder wird nur einmal
geschrieben weil das kann ich ja dann
nachher nicht mehr sehen ich weiß dass
porno und jetzt aber das alles noch ein
grundstück von der sinn meines borner
und ich durfte jetzt eigentlich hier
kein problem mehr mit spannung haben
also dürfte ich eigentlich nicht mehr
ich weiß nicht wie das in der realität
also in der relative betrachtet aussieht
du kommst jetzt allerdings erst mal
daran lädt sich schön auf
also schreibt mir das am besten einfach
meine kommentare einfach so ein video wo
ihr euch jetzt denken würde
ich muss zwar jetzt zur schule aber
sowas will ich mir einfach noch angucken
irgendwie sowas und jetzt sagt nicht
sprengen die stadt in die luft das ist
einfach nur an daten videos das bei den
sechser-gesprächen die stadt
nein aber ich fand's witzig von denen
also ich hab doch überhaupt nichts gegen
die man das ist ein spiel von daher
natürlich an gomez stellt mich natürlich
geärgert aber das sind andere themen
lassen andere themen wieder schnell dass
ein andere themen die kann man jemand
anders mal bequatschen mit sind wir
schon tausend mal durchgegangen wurde
schon tausend mal geheiratet der held
ist vorbei deswegen könnt ihr das jetzt
auch lassen und es ist wie gesagt nur
ein spiel und das megaprojekt alles ist
gut und wir hatten noch nie gedacht am
anfang von mega projekt das sich das
ganze so krass entwickelt wie es das
jetzt bis zu diesem zeitpunkt getan hat
mega projekt wie es ist sogar bekannt
und hat vielen amerikanischen youtuber
weil die deutschen youtuber immer mehr
steigen und so weiter und so fort also
ich weiß zum beispiel von so ein paar
amerikanern
sie zum beispiel leute auf dem heimweg
server diese mit halbwegs und kontakt
stehen die haben mich gefragt so hey
megaprojekt so geil ist es nur für
deutsches und servern meinte ich so ja
es ist ein server den viele von uns ist
die dachten wirklich das wären
gemeinschaft server wo dann irgendwie
jahrhunderts platz hat und jeder der
eine bestimmte abonnenten hatte
mitspielen
allerdings ist natürlich nicht so
sondern wir wählen natürlich die leute
aus die mitspielen dürfen wenn ihr euch
jetzt fragt warum ist dann kran kraft da
nicht dabei kernkraft als vision für
mich einfach eine seelische
unterstützung ich glaube in ihrem mega
projekt wäre dann wird einfach so
scheiße gehen weil er einfach so viel
besser ein feature bietet als ich mit
gebiet witwe ist als ich deswegen wird
es einfach total kacke ging an max
würden sie alle finden wir alle mega
sympathisch in der conti kennen wir auch
alle zumindest die meisten allerdings
fehlt ihm noch so ein bisschen so die
erfahrung mit youtube deswegen setzte
zeit noch nicht drin
mal schauen wie das dann alles mit dem
neuen projekt was sie mann und ich uns
super weitere planen so wie das dann so
aussehen wird auch mit euch unter
anderem weil eventuell wird auch eine
dings stadt gemacht eine stadt für user
aber da müssen wir noch gucken schreibt
meine kommentare wie sowas begrüßen
würde wenn wir so was machen also was
heißt begrüßen wir so was toll finden
würde begrüßen weiß nicht ob das wort
bei euch so gängig ist so und wir sind
fertig mit dem boden der ok können
trotzdem eine menge swan
da deswegen dass manche eben aus
ich muss am besten immer alles bonner
von mir irgendwo eine kiste tun
allerdings kann ich dir nicht abbauen
das ist ja auch wieder so das doofe als
packe ich darum wenig management so
alles schön auslösen damit auch ja nix
bond so dieses team muss vorweg was hat
sich für die verzauberung an breaking
selb touch ist fischen ziel sei die
fortune zwei jahre kommt es jetzt
bekomme ich dann mal zwei steine raus
oder was ich bekommen zwei steine ist
das jetzt hier mit weg wir ziehen das
einfach mit dem diamond will das geht
genau so schnell und danach können wir
noch so dinge sind den können wir
aufladen
allerdings wenn diese ladung hier alles
an welche den rest einfach mit der nähe
dann werde ich den ganz kurz noch mal
aufladen erstmal hier das den zweck das
produkt man kann mit dem ja nur seine
ganze blöcke abbauen als ich meine
relativ geringe lade dingsbums plan
ich denke ich jetzt in dieser aufnahme
definitiv nicht mehr schaffen wir level
27 nationen das wäre dann in der
nächsten aufnahme mit denen er dann
wahrscheinlich machen
seit mir deswegen dann da nicht böse er
sagt mir deswegen nicht böse
das mache ich dann einfach in der
nächsten folge schaut man jetzt ein
klick
es ist so heftig mega mega projekt
megaprojekte mega habe ich nie gesagt so
dass bei mir hier ein
darin da einen dahin da ein
und dann haben wir es eigentlich hätte
ich auf fast vergessen hier noch alles
weg hier schön die steinerne
interessierter keinen braucht auch
keiner
laut vfb stuttgart oder borussia
dortmund oder schalke 04 alle weg im
diamond race die brauchen ja eh nicht
ich weiß dass er die beiden zeitweilig
bayern fan bin nur deswegen guckte
hierzu einfach weil ich bayern fan bin
weil wir einfach mega ois is the story
wird sich dort muss jetzt einmal
tabellenführer so seit einem jahr so und
alle posten sie bei facebook jahr
fairytale beginnt blaha tabellenführer
ich stehe ja gut das ist ein anderes
thema fußball könnte ich mich jahre mit
anderen oder streiten
das ist erstmal meine putze die wird da
habe ich jeden fall noch ein bisschen
geiler
dann wird auf jeden fall noch so schönes
parkett reinkommen wahrscheinlich sogar
holz und dann würde ich sagen sehen wir
uns im nächsten mal wieder wenn es euch
gefallen hat will ich mich über ein mag
ich freuen und schreiben wir die
kommentare was ihr einerseits von mir
sehen würde worauf ihr richtig bock
hättet und andererseits so ob jetzt cool
finden würde wenn ich mal sieht man
vorschlagen würde so ne yo nachricht
hier mein handy so was so nach dem motto
je davon halten würde wenn wir seine
zuschauer stadt machen würden dann will
ich das immer vorschlagen bzw zu
allgemein mal so in den raum werfen und
dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
wieder